ce qui fait ma fierté comme métis c'est
un esprit un peu de nos ancêtres qui
nous suit leur courage de persévérance
la tradition et vouloir de processeurs
aux prochaines générations l'élite que
les plus métissés
il faut pas oublier ça et puis aussi ça
nous rappelle qu' on a le droit
d'exister
[Applaudissements]
de plus en plus personne se définissent
comme métier au canada elles étaient
près de 600 milles lors du dernier
recensement permet elle environ 80 de
femmes ils étaient des métis du manitoba
c'est qu'il honnit il faut le dire une
feuille de pierre sauvain vente et
médicis ça nous donne fierté et on est
quatre à deux tiers
[Applaudissements]
d'un bout à l'autre du pays la
définition de l'identité métier ce varie
selon l'histoire des communautés
si on regarde au manitoba les métiers
sont les descendants d union entre des
femmes des premières nations et des
voyageurs les voyageurs c'était des
employés des compagnies qui faisaient la
traite de fourrure il ya plus de 200 ans
il parcourait des milliers de kilomètres
en canot pour faire le transport des
pots exporté en europe
plusieurs voyageurs ont pris pour épouse
des femmes du pays et ont eu des enfants
les métis de la rivière rouge au 19e
siècle
certains métiers sa [ __ ] sur le
territoire qui appartient selon la
charte royale de 1670 à la compagnie de
la baie d'hudson au moment où la
compagnie veut le vendre au canada les
médecins craignent de perdre leurs
terres leur mode de vie leur religion et
leur langue
il forme un gouvernement provisoire
dirigé par louis riel en 1869 menée par
riel ils organisent une résistance à
l'arrivée de canadiens aient négocié
l'entrée du territoire dans la
confédération
ce qui permet la création de la province
du manitoba en 1870 les médecins sont à
l'origine de la formation du manitoba en
échange de leurs droits autochtones
le fédéral s'engage à donner aux enfants
des métiers plus de cinq mille six cents
kilomètres carrés de terres on leur
remet des certificats qu'ils doivent
échanger contre une terre c'était
représentent environ la superficie de
l'île du prince édouard
cela peut sembler beaucoup mais il
s'agit de -2% de la province du manitoba
aujourd'hui alors qu'il y avait une
population métisse majoritaire à
l'époque
la plupart des métiers ce ne vont jamais
recevoir les terres promises
ce sont des colons qui arrive dans
l'ouest qui les obtiennent fondateur du
manitoba avec lui elle il se retrouvait
dans une province qui ne leur
ressemblait plus la société de l'homme
blanc prenait de plus en plus de place
les métiers se vivent du racisme et fui
la province par milliers dans le nord
ouest notamment dans ce qui est
aujourd'hui la saskatchewan
la tension monte entre les métiers c'est
le gouvernement du canada
l'histoire se répète dans ce territoire
aussi le gouvernement veut obtenir les
terres sans tenir compte des droits des
métis en 1885 un lieu la bataille de
batoche les métis dirigée par louis riel
affrontent l'armée canadienne
trois jours de combats qui auront fait
25 morts et des centaines de blessés
louis riel qui a fait de la nation
métisse son cheval de bataille a été
pendu après avoir été condamné pour
haute trahison à regina en 1885
ça va prendre environ 100 ans a manqué
métier soit officiellement reconnu comme
un peuple autochtone au canada en 1982
louis riel et d'autres métiers savez
fondée en 1884 un organisme qui
deviendra l'union nationale médecins
joseph mais politiquement c'est la
fédération métis du manitoba qui
représente les métis de la province
auprès du gouvernement fédéral
toutefois l'organisme ne reconnaît pas
les autres communautés qui elle aussi se
disent métier comme celle au québec dans
les territoires du nord-ouest et en
nouvelle écosse le jugement daniel dit
que qui que ce soit au canada peuvent se
déclarer les tice c'est le droit de
chaque personne
mais laitier national quand celle avec
la mmf l'ontario saskatchewan revendique
pour une seule
ça me gêne aussi pour la multinationale
ouest s'appelait les netease la rivière
rouge le froid blanc serait super mais
il revendique un nom générique
d'individus qui se dit ce sont 18 c mais
tous ont une identité qui est
particulière et qu'ils veulent défendre
pour répondre à la question des parts
qui sont les métiers et bien dans tout
le canada il n'y a pas de consensus
on retrouve des communautés dispersées
qui ne sont pas reconnus officiellement
et communautés qui ont des droits
provinciaux comme les métis de l'ouest
et les métis de sault sainte marie
ils sont reconnus officiellement au
fédéral et en ce qui concerne les métis
de la rivière rouge
je laisse le mot de la fin à certains
métiers du manitoba forme impliqués dans
leur communauté
pour moi l'important c'est de continuer
à approfondir ma culture métisse en tant
que français canadien on aime s'amuser
on aime se recouper ensemble et aussi
d'autres aspects tels que comme le
perlage la fabrication de mocassins à ce
qu'il me manque un petit quelque chose
que nous vend cei peut faire sur la
seule province au canada qui est écrit
par un peu plus tôt tonnes c'est une
histoire passionnante
je souhaite que les métis se sentent à
l'aise et s'identifier et le de vouloir
vivre notre action dernier leur offre
leur métier shanxi
mais 150 personnes animent les métiers
de voir comme des temps des histoires
on veut retourner dans nos histoires
parler nos ancêtres et quand tu
accueilles d'une nouvelle histoire les
médecins mes petits enfants
soyons déjà la fiat et nous déjà la juge
contre vous je contacte de journée qu'il
ne faut pas se cacher comme nous l'avons
c'est une lutte pour comprendre notre
identité pour ce pour laquelle s'était
caché dans la famille pour plusieurs
années et de nous rappeler on est
toujours là et on continue et pour les
droits métis
[Musique]